hello everybody my name is bar gay bar
I'm still playing it's uh I'm not even
gonna say what time it is late
it's late so here we go tasty
tea right wha oh god it's a master sized
hater Oh is he gonna be on my table the
whole time well good thing I hang
on
II thought oh my my Grovyle this is
off to a bad start
I'll be back I'm legitimately devastated
I left my a SAS glasses on the plane
that I got off of five hours ago I kept
them specifically so that I could pull
them out to block out the haters I
hadn't thought of that on the plane I
was like hey I'm gonna pull these
glasses on make that joke it I'm
gonna eat this I'm gonna eat the
out of this goddamn t-rex literally I'm
gonna eat the straight out of its
butthole
yeah I'll suck it no I'm gone I'm
committing I'm gonna eat the out
it's boil and it's gonna die you think
you're gonna mess with me t-rex huh I
don't I may not have my ass ass glasses
but you better believe that you are
about to be eaten and something's gonna
happen to your butt I'm not 100% sure
what or how I'm very tired
I may have made promises that I have no
intention of keeping
but if anything that I think of where
did you even go guys see you later
haters I literally was thinking about
that on the plate I was waiting for the
opportunity that I could do that and the
opportunity came now and I can't do it
it's so stupid
okay anyway so I'm going to just do this
with skill since now I'm going to
actually concentrate I should have had a
cup of coffee or something but I plan to
go to bed after this I actually plan to
edit isaw ha ha ha
so boned I'm so own but that's okay
because it doesn't matter cuz I'm gonna
bug Annie that directs such tasty son of
a you know all these stupid dinos
ain't gonna give nothing against me I
mean I guess I could go full vegetarian
if I want to do and just eat bushes and
stuff I mean ah you're eating Wow
oh I did it
but it's not the same without my ass ass
glasses I cherish those things how could
I leave them on the plane I'm sorry I am
generally amazingly handsome and strong
and awesome but even I make mistakes
alright let's go I'm gonna eat my
feelings away and bye eat my feelings
I mean I'm gonna eat the entire history
of the earth oh that's a clever
arrangement of spines why is that like
that that way that it is who did this
huh very curious seems awfully
suspicious why did I get jumped it's one
point in time this is weird I mean if
you really think about it like really
think about why this is arranged like
this or how these dinos died to make
this happen
and how many severed heads have to be
strewn about in such a perfect order
it's legitimately horrifying so we're
just gonna make hurry hurry I mean I get
it it's a game I know I understand it's
a game
it's just posed to be set up for the
sake of gameplay play let's let's let's
let's let's get ourselves into the
reality of it for just a moment and try
to contemplate
the how and the why of it because the
how and the why of it are truly
terrifying what was I talking about
lalala arse I'm sorry I mean the sing
better than that I actually I actually
can sing better than that and what was
that well there was one song that was
stuck in my head I don't listen to a lot
of music but there was one song that was
definitely stuck and I'll be better when
I'm older whatever sleep I can
shout as loud as I want as late as I won
Zoya's here I'm just surrounded by my
crushing loneliness with no one to share
life experiences with or tell my
problems do there's nothing to oh god
damn it screw you completionist
oh it's like they arranged this very
specifically to be a mousse ah goddamn
unlockable pathways DLC I don't
appreciate I don't like it I don't want
none of it there we go now uh
now we're starting to break down the
walls of society here on our soda to
overthrow the government here or
degradation of our moral values in an
empty dude Oh big word platitude
platitude I'm a big dick idiot
my brain don't work anyway back to
the intelligent commentary which is why
you guys watch me right
so I'm now eating all the bones because
amazed and stupidness going on here
yeah there ain't nothin even left all
the careful arrangement whatever
psychopath killed all there it was
babies it was babies oh it was babies oh
it was babies oh no it wasn't babies oh
if whoa it wasn't babies that died no
just ate those things okay so it was a
graveyard in the stomach of another Dino
and we're not gonna here's your babies
I'm gonna assume that it was on
represent babies oh god why would it why
did I know to eat severed heads oh
that's horrible oh it was babies it was
babies all of it was babies that was
babies this is not okay for 4:30 in
the goddamn morning huh it was babies
what if my neighbor wakes up to me
shouting it was babies only the goddamn
cops called on me and then I'm gonna be
arrested away shouting it was babies the
whole time babies whose
babies well alright then them's the
breaks that's life I guess
oh god that's gonna take seven minutes
yeah let's do it I'm feeling Yolo I can
do it in record time I don't know how
big we're gonna get in this one but I
have a feeling it's gonna be gargantuan
big it's gonna be
intimidatingly big it's gonna be like I
don't know if I can handle that big you
know what I mean know what I'm talking
about still having flashbacks I mean if
you think about that I was complaining
about the meticulous layout of it and of
course it was meticulous layout because
the babies were still being made before
that Dino died I don't even know how
that Dino died cuz it doesn't sit there
seems to be a lot of death in this era
of time in the era of happy you know
lounge music but there seems to be quite
a bit of death in a lot of different
places that I should be generally
perturbed by what's going on here and I
am don't worry I am this is
bizarre in punkers and everything is
going yeah oh yeah I forgot I'm pissed
off that I left my ass
yeah so but on the on the bright side I
guess the only shining light of that is
that I um I got upgraded to first class
because it was delayed so much so many
people hopped off the plane that
basically there was only about 20 of us
left on the plane on the way over back
to LA so I just so happened to get an
upgrade and I do not fly first class
I bet on first class before but I do not
fly first class regularly because
expensive as hell but I it was an
enjoyable experience and it was really
weird because I can't drink for health
reasons and but there's free booze they
give you free booze and they were very
insistent about me getting free booze
and there were like 200 drinks beer wine
cocktails I'm like uh I have had a
bottle of water cuz they put a bottle of
water there for you and that was nice of
them so I was like order beer because I
can and then I didn't drink it and I had
to give it back right away because we
took off so quickly because no one was
left at the airport and all the planes
were already gone because it was
fricking late is free I'm gonna get the
Shrew but not the Dragonfly ow
oh no stampede get out of the way hater
shields maximum Oh God that's right you
better give up I mean you better give up
on a lot of things because you're not
gonna be surviving much longer
I mean it's admirable it's admirable
that he's chasing me down because he
might be the only thing that can stop my
horrible rampage even though if he does
eat me I'm just gonna be in his stomach
and eat him from the inside out that
sounded mildly sexual but it was not the
family-friendly show as I emphasized the
entire time that I was also sad for you
you're dead as I am beside the entire
time that I was at PAX my show is a
family show a show my inane ramblings
where I turn on my camera and then
upload the horrendous results to YouTube
for millions of people to see show right
out that entire name that's the name of
my show that bird got hate oh
hey Dan eagle Condor
Oh too bad for you you were trying to
me and now you've gotten eat mmm it's a
giant circle of life me specifically I
am the giant circle of life or I'm going
to be when I get so big that I
eventually consume the entire planet
which is the only end result of this can
happen because I'm literally the
greatest legend that every person you
know who I've been watching a lot of
lately because all I have you know all I
do is watch YouTube
mostly whose game grumps but I actually
started watching I've watched them or
him hurt them I don't know I've watched
bro science life a long time ago but
then I started watching it really again
when I was back in packs and God is so
funny like this is so unbelievably funny
like tickles my funny bone in just that
way and it's such a damn shame cuz
there's not that many episodes and
whereas something like game run thrums
game rums those delicious game rooms
that you get like 3 billion videos if
you first discover them and that's like
hitting a gold mine then you watch
everything for months and months and
months and they get three videos a day
and it's so much delicious delectable
con I love the game drums it's slightly
strange that I'm associating everything
with eating and I don't want to eat the
game grumps I don't want to eat their
delicious rumps it's not what I want
what I'm trying to say is bro science
life is a I legitimately forgot
what I was talking about I
I am blanking I am on my last leg I am
going as soon as I shut off the camera
Here I am collapsing in a note first I'm
stripping down naked collapsing in my
bed and then forgetting all my troubles
in la-la land but then I have to wake up
early to do the editing and the
thumbnails please these videos crying
out this was whoa my god I am just an
eco-terrorist
I am horrifying I'm so fast - I mean I
guess I'd have to be fast you think that
a giant blob of gelatinous machines
would be a little bit slower than this
but hey what are you gonna do when the
end of the
world is nigh man eat some trees yes oh
I can eat how's that how is how is that
I don't I don't understand how is that
how is that dude how's that do Oh God
whoa Nelly whoa whoa Nelly whoa Nelly
whoa oh is that is a lot of lava
flow so we'll admit by the world oh my
god holy crap whoa I didn't mean to do
any of this okay well we've reached a
new level of incredible and this is
amazing and I love it and my voice is
going I it is too early to be yelling
this much but holy what is
happening here so cool it's so cool it
just reached a level of cool I reached
that point where my vocabulary entirely
retains of its and so and cool and
that's all I'm gonna be saying for the
rest of this episode by the volcano oh
lore okay so we altered the
timeline and then we shrank back into
our normal size which is good because
then we can start over again going
through all of time destroying
everything sound good sound good so
thank you everybody so much for watching
and I will get some sleep immediately
after this but thanks again and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye
Ellis babies
sir are you the hawk did you stop me